what's up Gamers hello there everyone my
name's SCP explained a lot of SCP fans
have played the free survival horror
game SCP containment breach the game
story places the player in the shoes of
a d-class at one of the foundation's
containment sites as they try their best
to survive a massive catastrophic
Containment Breach many players
including some of our viewers feel as if
the simulated experience has given them
the tools they would need to survive a
real-life Containment Breach but can
playing a video game really be
sufficient training for encountering
some of the deadliest scps in
containment and escaping with your life
in order to answer this question we're
going to speculate based on one of the
game's most prolific players famous
YouTuber and gamer Markiplier if playing
this game counts as training then
Markiplier has enough hours long to be a
Bonafide expert in facing off against
the many dangerous anomalies at the SCP
Foundation so kick back crack open some
g-fuel and let's see if Markiplier lives
to game another day to set the scene
let's all imagine that somehow through a
hiccup in time and space or by some sort
of wish on a cursed monkey's paw
Markiplier found himself inside of an
SCP Foundation containment site that
would be bad enough but the blaring
alarms and sounds of chaos signal that
he arrived at the worst possible time
during a containment breach the security
systems are down the cells are open and
danger lurks around every corner armed
with nothing but his wits and winning
personality the only thing he can do is
try to navigate the facility as
carefully as possible remember
everything he's learned from his time
streaming the video game version of this
place and hope he can escape with his
life let's start with one we know he'd
be well equipped to face
SCP-173 the next snapping sculpture is
the main antagonist of SCP Containment
Breach so Markiplier would be familiar
with the necessary precautions to avoid
winding up as its
victim if he happened to walk into a
room and spot the figure Frozen in his
gaze he would know to keep his eyes on
the sculpture no matter what and slowly
back out of the room without blinking
plus with all the time he spends looking
at screens he's definitely used to
keeping his eyes on one thing for a long
period of time congratulations Mark you
survived that one he's managed to get
away from SCP-173 with his neck still
intact hooray but as he sneaks through
the hall try not to draw any unwanted
attention a French accented voice breaks
the silence behind him good evening my
fine fellow are you feeling quite well
there behind him is scp-049 the plague
doctor and all of his beak masked black
robed glory you look feverish please
allow me to administer some simple tests
in this scenario mark would have to
think fast and use some of that patented
Markiplier charm to get himself out of a
potentially sticky situation before one
of those gloved hands can touch him he
would need to politely excuse himself
insist that he just saw his doctor
earlier that day and then before the
plague doctor can take another step
closer run as fast as he possibly could
in the opposite direction as Markiplier
stops to catch his breath having thrown
the plague doctor off of his Trail the
sound of sobbing in the corner signals
that he might have just escaped the
proverbial frying pan only to wind up in
the fire a quick cursory glance up and
the sight of a long-limbed pale humanoid
form would confirm his suspicions yes
yes indeed he's found himself alone with
scp-096 the shy guy remembering the
details of this particular anomaly from
the game he would look back down at the
ground immediately making sure not to
Glimpse the creature's face as long as
he avoided looking at its face it would
stay in the corner of the room scarcely
even acknowledging him then he would be
free to make a Mad Dash for the exit all
the while scp-096 would stay hunched
over crying and completely aware it was
briefly in the presence of a beloved
YouTube personality things might be
going pretty well for Markiplier so far
but oh what's that sound the Slither of
tentacles on tile the thumping of a
large heart and the murmuring voice of
an elderly Englishman poor Markiplier
video games definitely wouldn't have
prepared him for the arrival of
scp-058 the Heart of Darkness it's come
out of its cage and it's doing just fine
but the same can't be said for any
living thing that this creepy animate
and highly hostile creature encounters
endless suffering is the woe of ignorant
men who never lack to see the depth of
their own hearts and only see the wealth
of a poor World suffering of silver and
brutal gladness the heart Whispers as it
scuttles towards the hapless YouTuber
without much prior knowledge of the
anomaly mark would be thoroughly
unprepared for any encounter with it he
would likely fall victim to its Spike
tentacles or the sharp stinger and any
attempt to physically fight it off would
be ineffective due to the anomaly's
resilience to physical attacks we don't
need to get into the details of how that
specifically might end it would be a bit
tasteless but there are friendly
anomalies that Markiplier might stumble
upon too suppose instead of suffering an
untimely end at the tentacles of a heart
monster that speaks in creepy
atmospheric gibberish he found himself
face to face with scp-073 Kane it would
be a nice reprieve to be sure as Kane is
generally Pleasant and congenial to any
humans he needs you never know he might
even be a fan of Mark's Work the same
can be said for Kane's counterpart
scp-076 however it's nothing personal
Abel feels murderous rage towards any
and all human beings but it's hard not
to take it personally when you see Abel
running at you at full speed brandishing
a massive sword that's poised to take
your head off with one swing if
Markiplier faced Abel on his own he
would unfold fortunately not stand much
of a chance again it's nothing personal
he's a super powerful ancient warrior
with a taste for Bloodshed if Kane was
in the vicinity however then he might
just be able to escape unscathed Kane is
one of the few anomalies that can easily
oppose Abel as any damage Abel manages
to do to him will only affect Abel so
the best case scenario for Mark would be
to let the two Immortals go at it while
he sneaks away quietly after all the
stress of navigating the containment
site Markiplier would probably really
need some cheering up after all his
entire sense of reality is crumbling
around him at a rapid Pace good news
because scp-9999 can always sense when
someone nearby needs that frown turned
upside down the Tickle Monster doesn't
appear in the Containment Breach game so
Mark might not know what to expect when
he sees a large mass of bright orange
slime oozing toward him at a rapid Pace
but once scp-999 wrapped him in a big
hug and its natural mood boosting
properties kicked in he would know that
this particular creature is friend not
phone he would give the slimy visitor
some affectionate paths and the Tickle
Monster would coo happily in return
scp-999 might try to follow Markiplier
down the hall but he would insist it
stay where it is needed helping the
various humans and anomalies of the
foundation when they need a little bit
of sweetness and light in their lives
then the two would part ways each with
their spirits lifted and with fond
memories of their new friend that would
last a lifetime but you can never let
your guard down at the SCP Foundation
not even for a second as you're enjoying
a hug from everyone's favorite happy
slime Creature if you relax and forget
to keep your wits about you you might
not notice the wall behind you starting
to warp and melt as something horrible
reaches through it from a dark place
outside space and time if Markiplier
turned around to find himself face to
face with the cold dead eyes of scp-106
the old man what would happen next the
rotten old man appear in Containment
Breach so mark would know exactly how
bad things can get of this ominous
octogenarian gets his decaying hands on
him he would also know that doors walls
and other solid objects are not enough
to deter this entity once he sets his
sights on taking you it is possible that
Mark could run could stay out of the old
man's sight until the creature gets
bored or find some other more convenient
prey to snatch up but it's more than
likely that scp-106 would be excited by
the Chase and would Delight in the fear
and pain that he is causing unlike in
Containment Breach where scp-106's
movements can be predicted the real
thing is far more crafty and malicious
and there's no starting over if the old
man catches up to you in the real world
unfortunately Markiplier would likely
find himself pulled through the wall and
into the entity's lair where only Doom
would be waiting how might Markiplier
fare against another prominent character
in Containment Breach though say one
very tricky possessive mask thank
thankfully his experience with the game
would have taught Mark in advance that
scp-035 cannot be trusted under any
circumstances however the mask in the
game is at least a little bit helpful
offering valuable information about
navigating the containment site and even
providing insight into other threats to
the player's safety the real thing is
nowhere near as generous it has no
desire to help humans or anyone but
itself really if it wound up in the same
room as Markiplier it would only have
one goal and one goal only get him to
take it out of its case and put it over
his face hopefully Markiplier would know
better than to wear the wicked porcelain
mask but its psychic influence is strong
we couldn't blame him if he wound up
succumbing to it putting it on and
becoming the mask's newest human host it
would be thrilled to have found such a
famous body to take over too who would
pilot Markiplier out of the containment
site take him back home and become the
first SCP with over 1 million YouTube
subscribers aside from this
I shudder to think what scp-035 would do
with such a massive platform it
definitely wouldn't be anything good now
there aren't just anomalies at the
foundation there are lots of Staff
members working to keep the well-oiled
machine running smoothly of course some
are better at this than others and some
staff are just agents of chaos all on
their own but that makes life more fun
Imagine a team up between the most
fun-loving memeable researcher at the
SCP Foundation and markiplier that's
right Dr Jack Bright himself now many
people don't know this but Dr bright is
a big fan of gaming YouTubers and has
wanted to start a Channel of his own for
quite some time the foundation won't
allow him to run any of his own social
media concern about the potential for
secure information leaking to the public
but a chance encounter with one of his
favorite YouTube creators would be just
the kind of opportunity Dr bright has
been waiting for sure Markiplier might
be caught a bit off guard by a strange
man in an amulet asking him to collab
but Dr Bright's big personality sense of
humor and high energy would make him a
great guest to have on the channel at
least until he finds something else to
distract him from his own existential
dread and abandons his streaming dreams
for that he definitely get Markiplier to
autograph The Amulet first though that's
for sure lots of people love Markiplier
he's a congenial guy with a passion for
making enjoyable content but there's one
anomaly at the foundation that wouldn't
like him at all in fact he would find
him frankly
disgusting but that's not his fault as
cp682 hates all living things that's
kind of its whole deal while that and
being impossible to kill the massive
rageville reptile is incredibly
dangerous to anything and anyone it
encounters and sadly Markiplier would be
no exception this creature doesn't care
about likability or how much a person
has contributed to contemporary internet
culture it only cares about destruction
about snapping the poor YouTuber up in
its Jaws or knocking him into the wall
with one swash of its enormous tail
unless Markiplier happened to have a
spare nuclear warhead on him it's not
likely that he would make it out of
meeting with scp-682 in one piece oh no
not his head wait is that The Bite of 87
sorry I had to do it for the meme
speaking of 87 however how would
Markiplier fare if he stumbled upon
scp-087 the stairwell it's not the
likeliest of events seeing as the
doorway leading to it is constructed of
reinforced steel with an electro-release
lock and is disguised as the entrance to
a Janitor's Closet in an undisclosed
building but in this world stranger
things have happened Markiplier has
played more than enough horror games to
know that finding yourself in a dark
staircase that seems to go on forever
where you can hear the distant cries of
a distressed child isn't something
anyone would ever want he could try and
descend the staircase looking for a way
out but if he did all that would await
him is creeping dread and paranoia and
an counter with a frightening face of
scp-087-1 his best hope in this scenario
would be to take a seat at the top of
the stairs and wait for his loyal fan
base to notice he hasn't been online for
a while the internet is a powerful thing
and it's possible they could track him
down and rescue him before things got
too dire otherwise well best not to
think about that over the span of their
careers many online personalities and
digital content creators have found
themselves in need of a Rebrand maybe
they decide to make a new type of
creative work maybe they wind up at the
center of a scandal maybe they just got
bored of doing the same thing over and
over again if Markiplier ever decided to
change things up there are dozens of
ways he could go about it but there's
one that he would need to visit the SCP
Foundation for it wouldn't be
necessarily advisable but what if
Markiplier decided to engage in some
anomalous self-improvement using scp-914
the Clockworks using live subjects with
this machine is always a bit dicey and
he would need to be extremely careful
about what setting he used the very fine
setting could produce some really
exciting results maybe it would improve
his eyesight or give him the ability to
work long hours without experiencing
Creator burnout maybe it would give him
the ability to fly or to spontaneously
generate a Wi-Fi hotspot no matter where
he was or how little phone signal he had
maybe it would make him the greatest
gamer in the world there's really only
one reason to find out just make sure to
hit the right button or several million
people would be very very sad speaking
of self-improvement what would happen if
Markiplier got his hands on an anomalous
computer program not one of the
Dangerous Ones but an educational one
intended to help children learn new
skills
scp-1594 Miss Jay's Wizkid Schoolhouse
would be a perfect fit he'd have to find
a way to play it on his computer but
once he did Markiplier could live stream
his experience with software it's
uncertain how the anomalous effect of
scp-1594 would translate into a massive
audience but it would be amazing to see
if thousands of people could learn a new
skill at once it would be potentially
life-changing for everyone involved
speaking of helpful anomalies Markiplier
would greatly benefit from an
introduction to
scp-662 the butler's handbell running a
YouTube channel takes a ton of work and
having an eager Supernatural assistant
on call 24 hours a day would probably
really improve the quality of life for
everyone involved Mr Deeds would be
happy to assist with whatever day-to-day
tasks might come up and could even
become a beloved background character on
the channel whether it's bringing Mark a
bag of Takis or helping edit video
footage there's very little this helpful
British Butler can't do when you get
famous and successful and when you
become a public figure online it seems
like everyone out there wants a piece of
you people want money attention to ride
someone's coattails to fame but what
about in an way that quite literally
wants a piece of Markiplier or any
person really
scp-082 Ferdinand the cannibal would
love to meet Markiplier and would love
to make Markiplier his meat he would
probably use his habit for lying and
spinning elaborate stories to attempt to
entice Mark into a dangerous situation
hello Markiplier it's me your friend
jacksepticeye he would say while very
visibly not being who he claims to be
it's time to film a new video challenge
see how long you can stay in the Soup
pot just hop in the pot of boiling water
don't mind me cutting up cards and
onions into it as long as Mark keeps his
wits about him and doesn't fall for the
extremely obvious lies he would likely
escape this confrontation without ending
up in a YouTuber's stew Markiplier is
somewhat familiar with the layout of the
SCP Foundation containment site thanks
to the gameplay of containment breach
but what if after freeing himself from
one anomalous nightmare he stumbled into
another one altogether what if months
after his explicable teleportation into
the containment site after life was
starting to get back to normal he was in
the market for a brand new gaming chair
and what if he decided to prioritize
convenience and Scandinavian furniture
Engineering in his selection process and
what if on top of all of that he had a
craving for some Swedish meatballs
consumed in a public food court why all
of those factors might just lead him to
Ikea and while there are hundreds of
Ikeas around the country it's not
impossible that he might just pick the
wrong one and find himself lost inside
of scp-3008 Markiplier is a fairly
observant guy so it likely wouldn't take
him long to notice that something is a
bit off inside of this particular retail
store there wouldn't be any other
Shoppers around him the aisles would go
on forever and the employees inside
wouldn't have faces that last one would
probably be the biggest giveaway
unfortunately when someone is inside the
infinite Ikea it's pretty unlikely that
they ever leave he would give it a noble
effort to be sure exploring his
surroundings and finding the best places
to hide from the Ikea staff when the
lights go out if his phone is fully
charged he might even be the first
person to live stream from the depths of
this anomalous furniture outlet and
spread the word to his fans about the
existence of scp-3008 but sadly that
stream would probably wind up being his
last unless he somehow figured out a way
to recreate his YouTube setup inside of
his strange new home if he did though
that would be pretty cool almost cool
enough to make up for the fact that he
would never see any of his friends or
family ever again fortunately for
everyone involved it's highly unlikely
that Markiplier will end up interacting
with any SCP anomalies without the safe
barrier of a computer monitor in between
them but just in case reality ever bends
in on itself and worlds begin to collide
hopefully Mark will remember everything
he's learned and to anyone who's ever
told you otherwise see playing video
games can help you in the real world it
might even save your life now go check
out
scp-963 what would you do if you were
immortal like Dr Jack Bright and the
whole story what if scp-096 wore scp-035
for more utterly bizarre what-ifs